[Music]
in the middle of this very cold winter
one chicago restaurant owner is on an
altruistic mission with a dual purpose
he's providing a warm meal for those who
need it while getting those to prepare
it
out of the frigid weather charlie damar
has the story
the sun isn't up yet on a freezing
february chicago morning
but robert magette is already on the
hunt
in minutes he spots maria palacio
bundled up behind her street cart
filled with his target 15 dozen steaming
tamales
we're hoping to buy out their stock of
tamales so they can go home and get out
of the cold for the day
maggit walks away with her whole supply
thank you
and palacio gets to end her day almost
before it begins
and her reaction was what disbelief
thought i was crazy
he's not crazy he cares
enjoy buddy maggit takes those tamales
to homeless shelters
and tent camps under train tracks
which is where mike williams lives we
consider it a blessing because
it's not often that we get a hot meal
so something so small like a tamale can
have a big issue that means a lot
at first his purchases were out of his
pocket the restaurant owner's way of
doing a little good
i saw a lady that looked like she was
dressed to be in
alaska and i just pulled over and i
asked her i'm like if i bought all your
tamales would you go home for the day
the idea took off after he posted the
pictures on social media
donations poured in buying the hot
tamales does a lot more than get vendors
out of the cold
it gives hope to those who need it most
we all need to have a little more
compassion for each other
and things will take care of itself
building community
through a corn husk for cbs this morning
saturday
charlie demar chicago we've said it so
much in the pandemic we have to help
take care of each other
we have to yeah who doesn't like a hot
tamale
what a great guy and you two do such a
great job of taking care of moist so
i appreciate you tamales tamales on the
way andre
chicken